hi this is presh hawker in this video
we're going to discuss a geometry
problem about two ladders and how it
relates to problems where people are
working together
imagine we have one wall with a height
of five and another wall with the height
of three
let's imagine there are two ladders
between the walls and we want to know
the height where the two ladders
intersect
in other words we want to know what the
height of the blue line is
we'll solve this problem by saying the
height is h
we'll let the distance on the left be x
and the distance on the right b y
now we can create a series of similar
triangles
so for the wall which has a length of
five we'll draw
one triangle
in green
and this smaller triangle right here
that we've drawn in green will be
similar to it
with similar triangles the proportions
are equal therefore five divided by x
plus y will equal h over y
for the wall with the height of three
we can also
locate some similar triangles
which we'll set out to the side
we can also say the proportions of the
legs will be equal so three over x plus
y equals h over x
we can go through a bunch of algebra
here and get that h is equal to 3 times
5 over 3 plus 5 which is 1.8
all the x's and y's cancel out
so that's pretty neat we can figure out
the height of the blue line
just from the distances of the two walls
now let's generalize the problem imagine
one wall has a length of a another has a
length of b
we can go through the same steps and we
can conclude the height is equal to a
times b
over a plus b
this is interesting it doesn't depend on
the distance between the walls
now let's consider another problem
imagine i take a hours to do a job and
you take b hours to do the same job
job how long will it take if we work
together
this is a totally different problem but
i'm going to show you how these two
problems are related
so let's draw a graph where the
horizontal axis is time and the vertical
axis is the percentage of the job
completed
if i do a job in a hours
that means it will take me a hours
to get a hundred percent of the job done
and i will linearly increase the
percentage of the job from zero to eight
hours
if you take b hours to do a job that
means you will complete the job in b
hours
going from 0 to 100 of the job completed
to see how long it takes to work
together we'll do a little trick we'll
flip the triangle
and now
imagine
that you are working from the end of the
job
and i'm working from the beginning
the point at which we cross
is the amount of time it'll take us to
work together
and that's the blue distance
if i translate over the purple triangle
and i move over this blue distance
and then i clean up the graph a little
bit
you'll exactly see that this blue
distance is the amount that we're
working together and the geometry is
exactly the same
as the previous problem we've just
solved
therefore we can conclude the time it
takes to work together is the same
amount a times b divided by a plus b
and that's pretty neat these two
problems are related
on a concluding note the harmonic mean
is equal to two times a b over a plus b
and both of these problems are equal to
half of the harmonic mean please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon catch me on my blog mind
your decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker and you can
get my books linked on my website